hello this week the NHS Tarn 75 a moment
of Celebration but also of trepidation
over the state of our health service
today record waiting lists strikes and a
public losing confidence in a treasured
institution all painting a picture of a
service struggling to cope and prompting
a national conversation about where the
NHS goes next
this week I hear competing Visions on
the future of the NHS from the health
secretary Steve Barkley plus his labor
counterpart was streeting can either
political party really stick with the
founding principles of the NHS to keep
it to Universal service free at the
point of delivery funded by the state or
does the NHS require radical change to
endure for decades to come
[Music]
well joining me in the studio to lay out
Labor's plan for the future of the NHS
is the shadow Health secretary Wes
Street in where's thanks for coming on
the show today now before we hear from
Stephen Barkley let me just get
something straight with you you
criticize the government for the
stewardship of the NHS but can you give
me an assurance that labor won't wheel
out that old attack line at the election
that the conservatives plan to privatize
the NHS and therefore labor are the ones
to save it can we just rule that out now
well I hope the Tories were all out
privatizing the NHS so I think there are
nonetheless
real signs of what I'd call a two-tier
NHS in in our country today where those
who can afford it are paying to go
private because they know they're going
to get seen faster in fact lots of them
are sitting in NHS appointments being
told if you pay to go private you'll get
seen faster those who can't afford it
being left behind
and that's not the kind of Health System
I want for our country but but I get
that but just to be clear you're you
know the the big 2019 attack from Jeremy
corbyn was they were going to plan they
were planning to privatize the NHS the
conservative government I think they're
running they're running it down and
they've ruled they've explicitly yeah I
think they have I think I think I think
they do accept that I think they have
what but what I would say is they are
running the NHS down we have got a a
different form of privatization by
stealth which is people now voting with
their feet and with their wallets
to go private because they don't think
the NHS would be there for them when
they need it people in this country
where streets and are fair-minded they
know there was an unprecedented pandemic
they know we're in the middle of a cost
of living crisis and high inflation is
hurting public services and eroding
their budgets all of it play into the
problems of the NHS isn't there a risk
that you look like you're trying to
capitalize on circumstances that to some
extent are beyond the government's
control and and the public will see that
for what it is well people are
fair-minded and so am I and any
government would have had to Grapple
with the extraordinary challenges of the
pandemic but while we're fair-minded
we're not Daft there are a hundred
thousand NHS staff vacancies before the
pandemic 112 000 vacancies in Social
care before the pandemic so it isn't
just they didn't fix the roof while the
Sun was shining they dismantled the roof
removed the floorboards and the NHS and
us as patients okay is more dangerously
exposed than we would otherwise have
been I'm going to quite forensically I
hope go through some of the plans of the
labor party but before we do that let's
hear now from the health secretary Steve
Barkley as he goes about defending the
government's 13-year record on the NHS
Secretary of State we are marking the
75th anniversary three of the NHS being
founded in
1948. by the time it hits its 100th
anniversary will we still have an NHS
funded by taxpayers with treatment free
at the point of view we're committed to
that and I think there's real
opportunities and we put out uh
announcements on for example Artificial
Intelligence on early screening of lung
cancer but do you think it's sustainable
the model is sustainable free at the
point of views I think the NHS will need
to evolve much more onto prevention
rather than simply looking at treatment
as we have the pressure of a growing
older population also people living with
multiple conditions one in four at the
British public now have two or more
conditions let's look at the state of
the NHS today after 13 years of
conservative government have more people
ever been waiting for NHS treatment than
they are now well we can see the impacts
of the pandemic pets I mean if we take
I'm gonna let me in a moment but if you
just let me answer the question so let
me give you a practical example going
into the pandemic there was around 1 300
patients waiting more than a year for
their operation at its peak that
increased uh to 410
000 but our plan on that is working but
record weightless is okay for people to
wait in a a e for over four hours no we
don't want people waiting that's why we
have a recovery plan it's why we're
investing more the Prime Minister knew
when you talk about the problems in the
NHS you always blame it on the pandemic
and actually if you look at the record
from 2010
deficits in NHS trust became widespread
by 2014 the NHS failed to kick he
waiting time Targets in 2014 and the
following years that's the Kings fund
again from April 2023 so in 2014 six
years before covid weighting targets
were being missed I mean are you saying
that this is a combination of austerity
followed by cuts and then the pandemic
that has put the NHS in the crisis it's
now in no firstly I'm saying the
pandemic has had a massive and not just
on the NHS in England but on the NHS in
Wales in Scotland and actually when I
talked with my counterparts on
Healthcare Systems across the globe
let's take elective treatment 92 of
people waiting for elective treatment
that's cataract surgery need
Replacements seen within 18 weeks from
their referral when was that Target last
met so again let's you know what I mean
this is not a gotcha question but my
point is do you know when it was last
met let's put it in context so we have a
plan in terms of elective recovery that
plan is working Mr Barclay that Target
was not missed that Target was being
missed in September 2015. my point is
it's not covered it's problems before
covert as well no one is saying there
weren't any challenges before the
pandemic indeed why the then prime
minister prime minister May brought
forward a long-term plan you acknowledge
that between 2010 and up to Theresa May
being prime minister targets were missed
that a long-term plan comes in then we
have the pandemic Target submissed
another long-term plan comes in a e for
our targets were last met in 2015 Cancer
Care targets last met in 2015.
do you see the point I'm making here yes
and the point I'm making is things like
the the four hour na Target in Wales
hasn't been met since 2009 and so yes of
course before the pandemic okay because
well your charge was this is down to
well you're the movement running the NHS
England which serves millions and
millions of us what I'm trying to make
the point to is just for you to be
straight with people about austerity
caused problems before covert has
exacerbated that those problems and you
don't seem to acknowledge that this is
partly on the conservative government
not just after the pandemic but the way
it was run for the past 13 years well
what I'm saying is that we're all you
disagree with that you don't think they
were funding Cuts what I'm saying is we
have Secretary of State we are marking
the 75th anniversary of the NHS being
founded in
1948. by the time it hits its 100th
anniversary will we still have an NHS
funded by taxpayers with treatment
free at the point of view so we're
committed to that and I think there's
real opportunities and we put out
announcements on for example Artificial
Intelligence on early screening of lung
cancer but do you think it's sustainable
the model is sustainable free at the
point of view I think the NHS will need
to evolve much more onto prevention
rather than simply looking at treatment
as we have the pressure of a growing
older population also people living with
multiple conditions one in four of the
British public now have two or more
conditions let's look at the state of
the NHS today after 13 years of
conservative government have more people
ever been waiting for NHS treatment than
they are now well we can see the impacts
of the pandemic path I mean if we take
a moment but if you just let me answer
the question so let me give you a
practical example going into the
pandemic there was around 1 300 patients
waiting more than a year for their
operation at its peak that increased to
000 with our plan on that is working but
record weights this is okay for people
to wait in a a e for over four hours no
we don't want people waiting that's why
we have a recovery plan it's why we're
investing more the Prime Minister knew
when you talk about the problems in the
NHS you always blame it on the pandemic
and actually if you look at the record
from 2010
deficits in NHS trust became wides for
2014 the NHS failed to kick he waits in
time Targets in 2014 and the following
years that's the king's fund again from
April 2023 so in 2014 six years before
covid weighting targets were being
missed I mean are you saying that this
is a combination of austerity followed
by cuts and then the pandemic that has
put the NHS in the crisis it's now in no
firstly I'm saying the pandemic has had
a massive impact not just on the NHS in
England but on the NHS in Wales in
Scotland and actually when I talked with
my counterparts on Healthcare Systems
across the globe let's take elective
treatment 92 percent of people waiting
for elective treatment that's cataract
surgery need Replacements seen within 18
weeks from their referral when was that
Target last met so again let's do you
know what I mean they've got your
question but my point is do you know
when it was last met let's put it in
context so we have a plan in terms of
elective recovery that plan is working
Mr Barclay that Target was not missed
that Target was being missed in
September 2015. my point is it's not
covered it's problems before covert as
well no one is saying there weren't any
challenges before the pandemic indeed
why the then prime minister prime
minister May brought forward a long-term
plan you acknowledge that between 2010
and up to Theresa May being prime
minister targets were missed that a
long-term plan comes in then we have the
pandemic targets amidst another
long-term plan comes in a e for our
targets were last met in 2015 Cancer
Care targets last met in 2015.
do you see the point I'm making here yes
and the point I'm making is things like
the the four Iron Man Target in Wales
hasn't been met since 2009 and so yes of
course before the pandemic is okay
because well your charge was this is
down to well you're at the moment
running the NHS England which serves
millions and millions of us what I'm
trying to make the point to is just for
you to be straight with people about
austerity caused problems before covert
has exacerbated that those problems and
you don't seem to acknowledge that this
is partly on the conservative government
not just after the pandemic but the way
it was run for the past 13 years well
what I'm saying is you disagree with
that you don't think there were funding
Cuts what I'm saying is we have invested
consistently in the NH as I pointed to
and I've pointed stuff out from the
king's fund that's exactly the opposite
the public satisfaction chart that I've
dug out which I can show you if you want
shows public satisfaction plummeting in
the NHS in 1997 18 years after a
conservative government and now in 2023
after 13 years of conservative
government it's now back at a record
high isn't the truth that the public
think that you have failed them on the
NHS well the truth is that we've got to
worry you when I tell you the truth is
we have the biggest other investment in
the NHS estate through over 20 billion
pounds going into our new hospitals
program we have a historic investment
induction we have a historic investment
if you let me answer the question so
you're not acknowledging my questions we
are investing record sums in the NHS
estate but at no point have you
acknowledged that funding Cuts hit
waiting lists up to 2020 and that has
been exacerbated by the pandemic and you
might not want to say that to me for
political reasons but I think people who
use the NHS feel it and then they feel
that you're not acknowledging their
truth so what I've acknowledged is there
were pressure on waiting times going
into the pandemic because we have an
older population
investing in our Workforce in our NHS
estate in the latest technology that is
how we build a sustainable NHS for the
future so keep the faith is your message
to the public yes okay Secretary State
thank you so much for your time
appreciate it thank you Secretary of
State we are marking the 75th
anniversary of the NHS being founded in
1948. by the time it hits its 100th
anniversary will we still have an NHS
funded by taxpayers with treatment free
at the point of view we're committed to
that and I think there's real
opportunities and we put out
announcements on for example Artificial
Intelligence on early screening of lung
cancer but do you think it's sustainable
the model is sustainable free at the
point of views I think the NHS will need
to evolve much more onto prevention
rather than simply looking at treatment
as we have the pressure of a growing
older population also people living with
multiple conditions one in four of the
British public now have two or more
conditions let's look at the state of
the NHS today after 13 years of
conservative government have more people
ever been waiting for NHS treatment than
they are now well we can see the impacts
of the pandemic pets I mean if we take
I'm going to uh
would you just let me answer the
question so let me give you a practical
example going into the pandemic there
was around 1 300 patients waiting more
than a year for their operation at its
peak that increased uh to 410
000 but our plan on that is working but
record weightless is okay for people to
wait in a a e for over four hours no we
don't want people waiting that's why we
have a recovery plan it's why we're
investing more the Prime Minister knew
when you talk about the problems in the
NHS you always blame it on the pandemic
and actually if you look at the record
from 2010
deficits in NHS trust became widespread
by 2014 the NHS failed to kick he
waiting time Targets in 2014 and the
following years that's the king's fund
again from April 2023 so in 2014 six
years before covid weighting targets
were being missed I mean are you saying
that this is a combination of austerity
followed by cuts and then the pandemic
that has put the NHS in the crisis it's
now in no firstly I'm saying the
pandemic has had a massive impact not
just on the NHS in England but on the
NHS in Wales in Scotland and actually
when I talked with my counterparts on
Healthcare Systems across the globe
let's take elective treatment 92 of
people waiting for elective treatment
that's cataract surgery need
Replacements seen within 18 weeks from
their referral when was that Target last
met so again let's you know what I mean
I've got your question but my point is
do you know when it was last met let's
put it in context so we have a plan in
terms of elective recovery that plan is
working Mr Barclay that Target was not
missed that Target was being missed in
September 2015. my point is it's not
over it it's problems before covert as
well no one is saying there weren't any
challenges before the pandemic indeed
why the then prime minister prime
minister May brought forward a long-term
plan you acknowledge that between 2010
and up to Theresa may be in prime
minister targets were missed that a
long-term plan comes in then we have the
pandemic targets amidst another
long-term plan comes in a e for our
targets were last met in 2015 Cancer
Care targets last night in 2015.
do you see the point I'm making here yes
and the point I'm making is things like
the the four hour na Target in Wales
hasn't been met since 2009 and so yes of
course before the pandemic okay because
well your charge was this is down to
well your investment running the NHS
England which serves millions and
millions of us what I'm trying to make
the point to is just for you to be
straight with people about austerity
cause problems before covert has
exacerbated that those problems and you
don't seem to acknowledge that this is
partly on the conservative government
not just after the pandemic but the way
it was run for the past 13 years well
what I'm saying is that we're always
disagree with that you don't think they
were funding Cuts what I'm saying is we
have invested consistently in the NH as
I pointed to and I've pointed stuff out
from the Kings fund that's exactly the
opposite the public satisfaction chart
that I've dug out which I can show you
if you want shows public satisfaction
plummeting in the NHS in 1997 18 years
is after a conservative government and
now in 2023 after 13 years of
conservative government it's now back at
a record high isn't the truth that the
public think that you have failed them
on the NHS well the truth is that we've
got the ability to worry you when I tell
you the truth is we have the biggest
other investment in the NHS estate
through over 20 billion pounds going
into our new hospitals program we have a
historic investment production we have a
historic investment if you let me answer
the question so you're not acknowledging
my question we are investing record sums
in the NHS estate but at no point have
you acknowledged that funding Cuts hit
waiting lists up to 2020 and that has
been exacerbated by the pandemic and you
might not want to say that to me for
political reasons but I think people who
use the NHS feel it and then they feel
that you're not acknowledging their
truth what I've acknowledged is there
were pressure on waiting times going
into the pandemic because we have an
older population
investing in our Workforce in our NHS
estate in the latest technology that is
how we build a sustainable NHS for the
future so keep the faith is your message
to the public yes okay Secretary State
thank you so much for your time
appreciate it thank you focused on
delivering a Neighborhood Health Service
bringing the NHS into the community how
does that work
well I think a number of ways I mean
it's partly about recruiting more GPS
it's also about making better use of
Community Pharmacy it's about new
services like Community Mental Health
hubs and it's about I think cutting out
some of the bureaucracy and red tape
that patients and professionals are
encountering and so that's what I mean
by fixing the front door to the NHS and
that's why Beth you know not to labor
the point about the money again there
are examples of how money is not well
and we've got to if we're going to ask
for more money we've got to deal with
those examples of waste a big expansion
there of of community care now you made
this reform speech at the king's fund
and they assess the plants themselves
and they said this is April 2023 there's
been a clear consensus for more than 30
years under successive governments that
moving care from hospitals to
communities the right thing to do so far
so good and then they went on previous
attempts to do this have failed
spectacularly translating these warm was
into tangible change for all patients
will require radical reform across the
whole Health and Care system from social
care to fully engage in the voluntary
sex sector to improving NHS buildings I
agree now but
but it's quietly damn in this in a way
it was because for this to work you need
social care reform you need investment
in NHS buildings and you're no closer to
a fundamental expensive reform of social
care than the current government
services have done that you need social
care reform
and that you need to improve NHS
buildings
yeah and we're up for it we're going to
be really busy if we win the next
general election we're ambitious for the
NHS and we recognize it's going to take
time and the point and we recognize it's
going to take what it is what I'm trying
to say to you is the point is is both of
those need some sort of funding
commitments yeah look we know that this
is going to be easy no we know it's not
going to be easy it's going to work a
bit but we know it's not going to be
easy and as with the last Labor
government as the economy grows there
will be money to invest in our Public
Services which is why economic growth is
our number one objective now can you
pledge that labe will go into the
election with a policy on adult social
care despite the political toxicity of
this subject you won't will you we will
but one thing I'm determined to do
around social care is avoid where we
have been and when I say we I mean we uh
in politics the main political parties
for more than a decade now of going into
every election shooting down each
other's ideas and hamstringing social
care reform and so and service change
but what I'm not going to do is is have
social care as a political football at
this election because I think we've been
there before you know yeah
the acknowledgment in all of this is we
we unpick a bit about kind of which bits
you can and can't do is that you you
seem to be acknowledging here
um that some of the reforms that labor
would want to to make if it was in
government in power you're going to have
to backload them to the end of a
parliament or even hope for a second
term because you won't have uh the money
in the public offers uh to fund
some of the uh projects and programs and
policy reforms that will be needed is
that fair well some of which some of it
we can get our skates on pretty quickly
actually in terms of in terms of in
terms of short well in terms of
short-term uh fixes in terms of uh you
know using the private sector to bring
down NHS waiting lists and allowing
people to do that free at the point of
use
that capacity is there yeah make better
do you see my bigger point do you
acknowledge that that because of well
not entirely not entirely Beth in the
you know on Workforce for example we can
get our skates on in fact one of the
reasons I'm not talking about work I'm
talking about social candidates but it
is also fundamental to everything else I
I accept that whether it's the NHS or
other areas of public policy there are
some things either
we'd like to do in the first term but
won't be able to or some things that we
would like to do faster but won't be
able to afford
but that means that when people pick up
a labor Manifesto
and they see the promises and the
pledges in it they can have greater
confidence that every promise is one
that they can keep and one we can afford
because to get into the manifesto as I
think people are seen in our interaction
it's a high bar there is an issue of
trust and credibility here uh Kirsten
made ten pledges to the labor party when
asking to become party leader they
included 0.5 which said these words end
Outsourcing in our NHS what did you take
to mean those words to mean
well I think that what care wants to
achieve and what I want to achieve is
better value for taxpayers money and
sometimes I think it is fair to say
um Outsourcing although notionally about
cost saving is Pennywise and pound
foolish
and what I would say more generally
about the pledges what do you take as
Outsourcing
well I mean a lot when he says
Outsourcing didn't he mean and private
provision well I'll give I'll give you
I'll give you an example I'll give you
an example is that what is that that's
what it was I wasn't it but I didn't
think it said that I'll just say one
more thing about kiers 10 pledges and
the issue of trust which is that when he
made those pledges
the world was yet to change with the
pandemic and with the absolute state of
the public finances
and
I hope that people take trust and
Confidence from the fact
that we are not going into the next
election making promises that we can't
keep that things that we might like to
have done we've had to quite honestly
say we're not going to be able to afford
to do a lot of Labor supporters labor
members will have maybe been shouting at
the television when you said that
because a lot of them will feel
that the reason that kirstarma made
these pledges or a number of them was
because he's trying to win the
leadership on the back of quite a left
leaning membership and he said what he
needed to say to win and then he changed
what he did and a number of uh labor
supporters might feel betrayed by that I
think that's a serious misrepresentation
of the mood of the labor membership no
one in the labor party is feeling
betrayed by a leader who has put labor
within touching distance of winning the
next general elections
well I'm sorry I promise
and then he's backed off well I'm afraid
they have to dry their eyes and be glad
of the fact that we might finally after
30 years get this conservative
government out and have a labor
government able to change our country
once again John McDonald was on
television on news night with an
interview with Nick what the political
to the same that kirstma is Drunk on
Power
to be honest I thought that was
extraordinary I thought it was
extraordinary because
what care has done
is take the labor party from its worst
defeat since 1935 when we weren't
trusted on a whole range of issues and
where people had been bullied and
hounded out of the labor party not least
through the issue of anti-Semitism and
he has taken that absolute shipwreck
that the labor party was in 2019 and now
made it seaworthy and I hope on course
for a general election Victory on the
substance you've you've made it clear
you're happy to use private sector to
increase capacity you talked about that
about it driving down waiting lists Tony
Blair's called for an expansion of the
private sector's role in the NHS in the
digital era would you like to see their
involvement grow I don't agree with what
Tony Blair said today so I think he's
talked about people having individual
health accounts with a budget they can
spend in the private sector I think
that's a step too far actually I don't
support that and similarly I don't
support what lots of conservatives have
been saying about charging people to see
a GP and expanding user charging in the
NHS I'm completely opposed to that I
believe in an NHS that's publicly funded
free at the points of use there for us
when we need it thank you so much for
joining me today that was a fascinating
conversation thank you
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversations with labors Wes Street in
and the house secretary Steve Barkley
plenty of food for thought in both of
them now if you scan the QR code on the
left of your screen you can watch all of
our previous episodes online
and if you scan this QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
Beth Rigby interviews podcast each week
I take a look at the highlights of the
interviews and there are some extra bits
and pieces in there too that's on the
Sky News app or wherever you get your
podcasts
well that's all for this week's show
thank you so much for watching
[Music]